what are they going to do they're going
to lie about everything whether it's Joe
Biden lying about the deficit and
inflation and all of that or it's just
mainstream media in general lying about
what's going on with crime and what's
going on with the woke stuff uh here do
we have the warning
there you go it's the ladies of the view
here's Joy Behar lying about crime I
want to say there is no both sides here
no and a lot of them like to say it
including Ted Cruz when he was here and
I'd like to remind everybody that it was
the Democrats the not the Democrats who
stormed the government that day and try
to kill the vice president yeah okay and
the Republicans now coming up to the
next election which is next week by the
way
um that all they do is talk about crime
crime crime well I looked it up
murders in major cities have fallen by
four percent so far in 2022 compared
with the same period a year ago so crime
is not on the rise it's actually going
down under
okay so we're going to give you some
stats
um Joy is a liar you know she's a liar
um the fact that she even mentions
January 6th it was the Republicans who
stormed the capital and tried to kill
Mike Pence I know a bunch of people with
no weapons who had no plans again there
was the guy with the Lego set and we
apologize for that
um it's just pure nonsense you know
what's happening in New York City and
joy you've lived in New York City all
your adult life I used to live two
blocks from you and when I lived there
in New York City I used to see you
wandering around every now and again I'm
guessing you don't wander around as much
I am completely confident in saying that
you are not wandering around New York
City as much as you used to because it
is not safe in New York City right go to
Midtown where it used to be bumbling and
and bubbling with people in suits going
to work doing things it just ain't
anymore it's a lot of people kind of
looking Shady wandering around and the
smell of weed everywhere it ain't safe
so anyway we're going to give you some
actual stats so she was almost sort of
right about one thing but there's a
little context that of course she left
out uh here's some info from axios
overall violent crimes spiked 4.2
percent from January 1st to June 30th
2022 compared to the same period last
year the survey by the major cities
Chiefs Association found robbery
skyrocketed by nearly 12 percent and
aggravated assaults increased by about 3
percent the survey of 70 agencies found
now here's the real interesting one from
Time Magazine homicides and other
violent crimes dropped slightly in the
first half of this year compared but
violence in major American cities Still
Remains dramatically higher than it was
before the pandemic the new statistics
come from the Council on criminal
justice which released its mid-year 2022
crime report on Thursday examining crime
rates from 29 cities homicides decreased
by two percent between January and in
June 22 compared to the same period in
21 okay however the slight decrease is
less satisfying when considering that
homicides that's murder people hit
historic eyes in some cities in 2020 and
2021 the homicide numbers for the first
half of 2022 which are based on data
from 23 cities are still 39 higher than
they were in the same period of 2019. so
this is also one of those ones where as
I often say you can't totally get lost
in the numbers there's a little bit of
reality that you just have to feel if
you are let's say a small business owner
in New York City do you feel confident
that your windows are not just going to
be broken the next time antivo or BLM
wants to March through and Destroy
things say after a midterm election when
it doesn't go the Democrats way and they
decide to kind of release the pressure
again with a little little violence a
little let's burn down to Pep Boys on a
Target right